but first last night we played you this
disturbing video showing a group of
illegal immigrants in Times Square
viciously attacking NYPD officers last
weekend now the suspects they were
arrested they were taken to jail but as
per New York law sadly they were quickly
released due to New York's disastrous
Nobel laws and two of the illegals were
caught on tape given the middle finger
as they waled out of jail that was very
very thoughtful of them Senator Marco
Rubio up perfectly in a tweet he wrote
quote message to America from one of the
illegal uh immigrants who assaulted NYPD
officers walk free with no Bell and
heads back to a shelter funded by
taxpayers and now according to new
reports tonight four of the men charged
they've now successfully fled to Gavin
Nome Sanctuary State of California good
luck getting them back to New York for
their court date earlier today New York
Governor Kathy hoko she was asked about
the suspect she offered this response
take a look any response to police
searching for additional suspects in the
Time Square attack on police get them
all and send them
back you don't touch our police officers
you don't touch any wow all of a sudden
a change of heart from what New York
Governor hokel after all it was her
policies that helped lead to the vicious
attacks and by the way let's take a
little trip down memory lane you might
remember when she said uh this kind of
thing take a look we want people to come
here despite where they came from or
despite the circumstances that drove
them to this country and to this into
this state we see say you are welcome
here we welcome with open arms and we'll
work to keep you safe we'll not only
house you but will protect
you oh they were welcome until they got
the bill and the three and fourstar
hotel uh uh rooms that they were given
to illegal immigrants in New York City
all right this Biden made Christ it
needs to end right now illegal
immigrants they're just pouring into
this country they're coming from these
countries we keep reminding you Iran
Syria Afghanistan China Russia some of
our top adversaries but now we also have
top retired FBI officials warning
Congress of the danger calling this an
invasion of military AED men and just
today ice officials announcing that they
captured a known terrorist who illegally
entered the country back in March of
2023 and it gets worse according to new
report in the Washington Washington
examiner a watchdog investigation found
that your tax dollars they're being
funneled directly to illegal immigrants
according to the report illegal
immigrants coming to the southern border
they have received over 1 billion in
money cards envelopes of cash and other
benefits all paid for by you the
taxpayer not only is Joe aing and ab
betting in the law breaking he's now
using your money to pay illegals to
break the law
so what's Biden's big solution well he
says he needs Congress to help him
secure the Border no that's another lie
uh he said he's done everything he can
no Joe is lying he doesn't need Congress
at all Joe can simply reinstate all of
the Trump error policies that were
working at the most secure Border in
history and he can do it with the stroke
of a pen just as quickly as he undid
them with a stroke of the pen and by the
way some members of Congress didn't
exactly Inspire confidence with their
votes today look at this in the House of
Representatives they passed a bill to
deport illegal immigrants uh found
guilty of drunk driving but 150
Democrats voted against the bill why
would anybody be against this this is
the radical extreme you know new green
deal climate alarmist religious cult
Democratic party of today this is a
clear and present danger to the entire
country and even worse radical Squad
members like Corey Bush and
congresswoman TB they voted against the
bill Banning Hamas terrorists from the
US you can't make up this Insanity now
the legislation says that no person who
quote participated in planned financed
afforded material support to to or
otherwise facilitated the October 7th
Hamas terrorist attacks on Israel or
attacks uh after that shall be
ineligible for any relief under the
immigration laws how did Democrats 150
of them justify allowing even known
terrorists into the country they have
lost their minds and while Democrats
refuse to do anything to secure the
borders well Texas governor Greg Abbott
he's taking the necessary action by the
way with the help of 25 Republican
Governors around the country uh who
deserve a lot of credit but he is
refusing to cut down the razor wire he's
leaving the Texas National Guard in
place and legal pass he has the support
of nearly every Republican Governor
across the country including Florida
Governor Ronda santis who today
announced he is sending his State's
national guard to help and assist what
he is calling an invasion take a look uh
so today uh we are going to fortify our
presence along the southern border uh
we're providing up to one battalion of
Florida National Guard uh as well as uh
our first ever deployment of the Florida
State guard and the goal is to help
Texas fortify this border help them
strengthen the barricades help them add
barriers help them add the wire that
they need to so that we can stop this
Invasion once and for all by the way
Governor D santis will join us in a few
minutes but first our very own bill
maluan he is reporting that there has
been a significant shift in illegals
entering Texas with more than 70% of the
border crossings of illegal immigrants
in the last week of January taking place
in Arizona and California not Texas
maybe Governor Abbott chased them away
anyway Bill maluan joins us now with a
full report tonight
Bill hey Sean well we got some new data
we've gotten from CBP sources that shows
illegal Crossings in Texas have just
plummeted in recent weeks and now a
large majority of the traffic is moving
to Arizona and right here to California
so let's dive into these numbers here
take a look CBP source is telling me in
the last week of January there were more
than
32,800 border patrol apprehensions of
illegal immigrants across the southern
border about
23,500 of those were in Arizona and
California that is 71% of the crossings
in the last week so why is this
happening well Texas's Del Rio sector
which includes Eagle Pass was seeing
massive illegal Crossings back in
December some days with 3 or 4,000 in a
single day we all remember this viral
video just showing how bad it was there
well since then Mexico has started
increasing enforcement on their side of
the Border this was after a late
December meeting with us cabinet
officials and Texas as we've been
reporting has locked down their side of
the Border they've taken over Shelby
Park and Eagle Pass they've kicked the
feds out and they've been fortifying the
area with Legions of Razer wire soldiers
and Troopers and we'll talk about the
impact enforcement has had on both sides
of the Border look at these numbers
according to CBP sources border patrol
apprehended over 7 1,000 illegal
immigrants in that Del Rio sector in
December well that number dropped to
just under 177,000 in January that is a
76% decrease in a single month it's
great to see the result where we're
seeing the numbers that have now
plummeted I think we're now down to like
200 a day rather than the thousands that
we've seen sitting there in Eagle Pass
now you're seeing the numbers move to
California and Sean you mentioned
earlier uh Florida Governor Ronda santis
announced today he is sending hundreds
of Florida National Guard soldiers and
Florida State guard to Texas to continue
to help the state it was actually
Florida Governor Des santis who was the
first governor back in 2021 who sent
state troopers to Texas where they've
been assisting Texas DPS in the National
Guard and making apprehensions of
illegal immigrants we'll send it back to
you Bill Bill do you have any update on
Joe Biden's Friday deadline remember you
had a deadline Friday that uh the CBP
would have the right to cut down the
razor wire interestingly they came came
out with statements their Union came out
with statements saying they have no
intention of cutting down that razor
wire they they pretty much vo their
support for everything the Texas
National Guard has been doing there have
been a lot of Democrats wanting Joe
Biden to federalize the Texas guard any
updates or is Joe G to just let that
deadline come and go like most
deadlines the feds back down they
blinked uh they gave him a Friday
deadline Texas basically laughed at him
said nope we're not doing it and uh
attorney general Ken Paxton actually
sent a letter to the feds basically
saying your request is denied so no
Texas did not give in all right Bill
maluan great work at the border thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else